the Duke circle is full of clever
bastards but no one is like Jed - his
home is supposed to be full of marvels
and there's a reason people are afraid
of his mansion Emily take care of this
crazy man in his clockwork soldiers then
bring Sokoloff back he means a lot to me
CD PNG HIV XY z--
anyone here sir
show yourself [ __ ] the clockwork
[Music]
all right I need to find anton sokolov
welcome to my home stranger the door is
always open to those with the will to
pass the threshold if you're here by
appointment then proceed and bide your
time otherwise I'd inform you about the
defensive mechanisms employed here which
are quite formidable many have entered
without invitation
ah the space behind the walls
do you think this thing can see what
we're doing no when they're like this
they're blind they can still hear though
though we got that any loud noise or if
a fight breaks out it's still kind of
creepy I have to work hard learn more of
them I find it kind of exciting it's
like being watched
but not really
is Jin - guy you need us
most people are happy just doing a job
we're moving at last but where is gene -
it's one of the clockworks
some sort of maze it's obviously a
chamber for conducting experiments and
tests how have you know you could barely
wind along gin - isn't here
do you suppose were in danger
my desire to purchase
okay the machine is experiencing
uncertainty Sokolov
[Music]
and it be with that young emily kaldwin
Anton save your strength
I came to take you out of here you'll be
safer in the carriage Sokolov men io Jin
- a visit
[Music]
you